so I think we found the one thing worse
than fake outrage fake righteousness we
are here today to cross a very important
threshold in American history we are on
the precipice of a great historic moment
dealing with protecting the Constitution
this historic moment the gravity and the
historic nature of this moment the
solemnity gravity of the moments in our
history its you square in the back like
they have pompous Tourette's thresholds
thresholds precipices gravity jackasses
yeah in order to sell this sham to
America they put a wedding dress on a
sack of dog turds and rolled it down the
aisle
Edie what about all that walking huh
yeah let's look at them walk oh these
idiots can walk in a straight line
without tripping over their own egos
I've never seen a media this excited
celebrating the fact that these
half-wits can wallow towards an open
space we learned that's one word for
here they are walking and here they are
walking some more oh and did you see
them walking here oh and oh look at this
walk that's a nice walk
some more walking that's walking and
this walking there you go
and yet the media lapped it up got a
head into the dams if they put the money
in the jukebox and how the press dances
just the ceremony of it walking over
delivering the articles of impeachment
you'll see they're signing pens they're
the presentation and the pomp and all
that contributes to that gravity we see
the pomp and circumstance and the
formality and the seriousness the
building is filled with statues to
remind us of people who are the great
people before us there's a sacramental
quality to this they say there's a a
ritual we're not seeing the managers
walking back from the Senate through the
return job I think Pelosi is a real
believer in this about ritual I think
she's very reverential thanks Chris but
you also think the blow-dryer at the gym
isn't just for your hair
ceremony statues sacraments ritual
there is Gideon's Bill Clinton at a
slumber party and they can't even hide
it that's the real point the
breathlessness reveals their bias so is
this really historic they say it's the
only the third time someone's been
impeached but that's irrelevant if the
process is abused anyone can do an
impeachment if you have control of the
house and since the Dems now broke the
seal you're gonna see a lot more of it
that's the historical nature of this
it's now no longer anything special
now impeachment is going to be as
regular as me on Metamucil am i right
Adam I may have a pencil neck look at
this face the Washington Democrats are
wasting America's time with demented
hoaxes and crazy witch hunts mmm prove
it
so there are seven impeachment managers
take a look at them have you seen a
sadder collection of buffoons
they look like rejects from People's
Court now remember when you watch these
lemmings and act this phony sanctimony
your footing the bill so they're
crapping on us while we sign their
checks gotta remember this so when it's
over there's payback we got to vote him
out and never pay them an ounce of
respect ever again and don't forget this
is all due to the fact that they can't
be Trump so impeachments the next best
thing
but like all their big dreams after the
build-up it always collapses collusion
obstruction Kavanagh Covington avenatti
their big strategy always deflates in
their arms like a punctured blow-up doll
am i right Adam a bounty of snacks but
how to access them in such a small space
oh you bill no you're too big big to fit
in the machine don't twist my words come
back later tell bill I'm looking for him
I can wait I can wait for you bill
my god meanwhile Trump rolls along
signing trade deals killing terrorists
and chaperoning a record stock market
it's almost as if impeachment is a
vitamin that makes him even more
effective plus he has so many other
concerns I mean how about the shower how
about the shower you go into a shower
and I have this beautiful head of hair
any level and you go into the shower
right you turn on the water drip drip
drip but what about the light bulb I
brought back the old light bulb better
light for much less money if you want it
somebody said oh sure don't mention the
light bulb
you know it's hard to make an elegant
speech up so I got brought back to life
up so the new light bulb course you're
five times as much and it makes you look
orange and I was more interested in the
orange that I was in the Kos but wait
what about the refrigerators I'm talking
about refrigerators probably won't in
the State of the Union not leave it out
because I want to get praised for making
it you cannot make a brilliant speech
where they say that was such an
incredible elegant speech if I'm talking
about dishwashers sinks toilets light
bulbs
but six toilets and showers you'll get
any water he can't he cannot help
himself I hope at least he's approving
new dishwashers
I'm also approving new dishwashers that
give you more water so you can actually
wash and rinse your dishes without
having to do it ten times he speaks for
all of us
anyone have a new dishwasher anybody
have a new dishwasher I'm sorry for that
I'm sorry for that it's worthless they
give you so little water you ever see it
air comes out so little water so what
happens you end up usually get ten times
and the plates then you take them out
and do them the old-fashioned way
I wonder if he's done with the
dishwasher so dishwashers down they're
going to have just as much as you've
ever had and you're gonna use now one
shot your dishes are gonna be beautiful
I'm sorry that you just bought one of
those brand-new pieces of garbage but
darling the people go all right let's
face it we don't deserve him
because here he is trying to solve big
and little problems around the world
from trade with China to her ran to your
crappy appliances but he's only got one
question in mind how do I make it better
his opponents only questioned how can we
stop him the answer is they can't in
fact the more you try to stop him for
some bizarre reason the better he does
right at him and now [ __ ] those on a ski
trip I'm really excited about this ski
trip I cannot wait to hit the slopes
I heard it's supposed to snow all week
oh my god let's get it ready for some
fun in the Sun fellows Adam where's your
ski gear dude are you freezing it's like
20 degrees the only degree I care about
is this one from Stanford where did you
get that Stanford no like where did that
physically come from California maybe
should it come Adam maybe you should try
having relations with a woman
[Applause]